some more breaking news this hour just
in here at Al Jazeera officials in South
Korea say dozens in Cardiac Arrest
follow following crowd surge at
Halloween festivities in Seoul that's
according to the young hap news agency
president Yoon sukiol has apparently
ordered officials to swiftly administer
first aid and treat people on the scene
Kim is on the line in Seoul what can you
tell us at this stage
yes the incident happened around about
an uh an hour ago in Taiwan and iteran
is a famous Entertainment District in
Seoul and today lots of lots of people
came out to Italy this evening it seems
a lot more people came out to this
Entertainment District because it's a
Halloween weekend and then the the Main
Street and the elite in 10 world were
packed with a lot of people everywhere
and yeah I have been seeing social media
videos and their incidents happened and
it appeared to be a stampede and then
after that rescue workers and ambulances
arrived at the scene and there are lots
of people were lying on the street lying
down the street unconscious and then the
rescue workers had to perform the TR
immediately and after that some people
were taken to hospitals on abilities and
yeah some people work uh seen a taken to
one side of the street and the airplane
keys were covered on their body so so
it's not clear uh the the exact medical
conditions of them but then at least
dozens of people were seen uh without uh
breathing properly so as you mentioned
in your intro pressure news on Neo had
ordered officials to Swift swiftly of
the minister first date and treat the
people
all right listen Ken look thank you very
much uh for all this this news just
coming into us here at Al Jazeera that
dozens are reported to be in Cardiac
Arrest following a crush of people at a
Halloween festivities in Seoul thank you
very much